Michelle your mom she sounds formidable
uh so I love this story so you you
graduated from dance school you go home
to Malaysia and what has your mother
done
ah so as I got home for the holidays and
I was planning to go back to England
then she suddenly looped into this whole
thing about oh you know you should go on
stage more and you should do this
because now you're 21 and when you're
not 21 anymore the things you can do and
I'm thinking what on Earth is she on
about the next thing I knew was my
brother she looped my brother into doing
he said yeah yeah you should try it out
I'm like what are you guys she had
entered me for Miss Malaysia
wow he actually signed the form so
technically I'm not legit but but you
but you would think oh terrible things
to do you won
[Applause]
oh wow I did it to shut her off
because she wouldn't stop about it so I
said we had a deal if I do this you are
never going to do something like this
again
at what age were you when she insisted
on coming on a date with you oh
now you have to remember they're very
very moms are very protective right for
all the right reasons so oh she always
went on a date oh always always until I
went to England to study I don't know
why she even let me go to England so
when we go on dates she literally will
sit I'll be here the guy was here and
you know we're 17 or whatever so one
time I was sitting like this and I
suddenly realized why are there two
hands on my leg so it was his hand on my
mom's
he was holding the hand he thought was
mine and then I looked at like
excuse me guys
[Music]